this is our Vallejo factory all of our
homes are made here now we have a
proprietary structural steel frame that
we use as the start of the house
that's patented it allows us to build a
house completely in the factory fold it
to a width of 8 and a half feet so it
can transport on a standard truck and
ship it anywhere in the country
this section right here we take the
steel frame and we do the end lays for
the floor and you can see in the middle
section the hinges this is where the
floor will fold we seal all of the
joints for air infiltration all the
walls they're wired they're plumb when
you unfold it the customer and anyone on
site is going to see a completed kitchen
all the cabinets the refrigerator the
rain everything's finished the structure
is so strong that by the time we fold
this down we don't have any breakage on
our windows and doors they arrive on the
truck the crane picks up the module off
the truck puts it onto the foundation
the house actually unfolds like an
origami and then the walls kind of swim
over it
as a customer you design a home with our
architects and then eventually they
create a 3d model so it actually helps
our factory floor with the electrical
plans the plumbing the structural and
all that the demand is very high growing
two to three times a year what we've
seen before is that the module industry
couldn't ship really high quality homes
very far from a factory traditionally
they had height restrictions for
shipping we have a holding technology
which allows us to basically deliver
really high-end high-quality
indoor/outdoor living high ceilings lots
of glass and if you look at your phone
your car it's all precision built to the
factory we believe that the quality is
actually higher in the factory so we're
just taking a different take on prefab